value your time it is all you have it is
more important than your money it's more
important than your friends it's more
important than your anything your time
is all you have do not waste your time
what was the one most important thing
you did to become successful
yeah
anyone who's known me for a long time
knows that my defining characteristic
it was actually
a combination of uh it's not
intelligence it's not reading it's a
it's a combination of
um
being very
uh
impatient
and willful
so i don't like to wait
i hate wasting time
i'm very very famous for
being rude at parties events
dinners where if i'm sitting there and
the moment i figure out it's a waste of
my time i get up and i leave
i went to a dinner at a friend's house
recently
where it i went with my wife and it was
a small intimate 12-person dinner party
and we were supposed to and my friend
had put together a very elaborate affair
where we were going to sit there and it
was like this fancy thing where you're
blindfolded and then other people kind
of feed you for four hours while you
have conversation
and that sounded terrible to me and so i
got up and i left after 10 minutes even
though it was this massive paid event
supposed to be very fancy dinner and my
friend understood because he's a good
friend of mine and he knows how i think
so he let me get away with it but i've
been doing that my entire life the
moment i figure out something is a waste
of time i leave immediately immediately
so i have no time for tedious dinners
tedious ceremonies tedious people
i have no time for formality
i have no time for dressing up i have no
time business trips like
i look back on my this this happened
about five or six years ago i looked
back on my career and i
looked at all the business trips i've
taken in my life and i said how many of
these were actually worthwhile
especially given that i had to spend
three or five or seven days away from my
home my family and all the productivity
that i could have had both in business i
had to ruin my health because i'm eating
out i'm not working out regularly and i
came to the decision that business trips
are never worth it so i just stopped
going to business trips and
all of this is broken glass it does
annoy people but fundamentally where i'm
going with this is i value my time
value your time it is all you have it is
more important than your money it's more
important than your friends it's more
important than your anything your time
is all you have do not waste your time
and that doesn't mean you can't relax i
mean what am i doing right now i'm
wasting time on periscope by some
people's definition but i'm doing what i
want so that's okay so as long as you're
doing what you want that's not a waste
of your time but if you're spending your
time not doing what you want and you're
not earning and you're not learning then
what the heck are you doing don't spend
your time making other people happy
other people being happy is their
problem it's not your problem if you are
happy it makes other people happy if you
are happy other people ask you how
you're happy and they might learn from
it but you are not responsible for
making other people happy
[Music]
[Music]
you